I know if you guys know this but the UN
said is one of its millennial goals in
the year 2000 to have the rates of
poverty in the world by 50% within 15
years right and we hit that in 2012
three years ahead of schedule it will
have fastest decrease in human poverty
that has ever occurred in the history of
the planet by a massive margin and it
hasn't quit now obesity is a bigger
problem now than starvation it's like we
should have party in the street for that
right there's more fat people than there
are starving people you know it's a
perverse sort of victory but but it's a
big one and about three hundred thousand
people a day right now are being plugged
into the electrical grid and the
fastest-growing economies are in
sub-sahara Africa sub-saharan Africa
it's like there's some real reason to be
thinking things are going great in there
having Amazon and Alibaba compete to
provide them with those goods that they
need every little bit yeah well they
have cell phone technology that's really
made a big difference and help stabilize
the currencies and help them identify
where the proper market is for their
goods and and they're being plugged into
YouTube and watching Jordan be Peters
and videos now yes well